i'm richard and i'm standing at the
election as an independent not for any
party yeah not for any party I just
follow just want to change everything
just want to change the way government
works and the way the fact that they
don't look after us they look after you
know big business and yeah so well you
know there's always hope with just eight
weeks to go independent election
candidates across the country are
fighting to get their messages heard
forgive you want a reporter for the
river to put only a handful of
independent MPs have made it to
Parliament in the last 60 years and
going up against the big parties is done
but many everyday citizens are
determined to be elected i think i am
going to win oh no I didn't say that
this is the story of what it's like to
go it alone in the general election
chartered tax advisor Richard lux and
Darnell dreams of being an MP he's taken
three months off work to campaign and
today he's canvas and local businesses
in Cheltenham you're thinking is this
guy so I've got a question for you
you've got just introduce myself
selling is an independent yes I'm yeah
right yeah really put the cat amongst
the pigeons aren't you well trying to
trying to change the wind and change
them I change the debate 2005 size of
this target is you can't you can't start
doing something that like this without
viewing you thinking you can win I
probably ought to say that no
immigration is a big issue yeah people
are going to be talking about it a lot
yeah but you need to know that I from my
perspective I love the fact that we have
an immigration population that people
come and it adds to the vibrancy of the
community and you're very welcome that's
your first taste of business door
knocking yeah that's a lot of fun it was
really good we've just spent a good 45
minutes going door-to-door porridge at
about 15 businesses something like that
how many votes you think you got an do
you think it's worth it do you think the
time it you just spent is worth it I
think it is worth it because you have to
remember that that these people run
businesses and by their very nature
being on the high street they have
people go in and out you know so they
now have the conversation to your story
you know as much as them as individuals
they will now be able to say to their
customers the hairdresser oh you never
know you never guess who I had in my
shop this morning you know do you think
he'll say that well I think I think
somebody out of that lot yeah a number
of people will actually say that let's
go
thinking is that I want to be borders I
think to do that I'll they're just wave
a favor where will we up with a question
no good on question time there would
have so many waves up me when it comes
to building a profile taxi drivers
Steven picton has taken an unusual path
youtube videos and charity performances
have helped him become well known in the
town
you and I broken
I've got one that faces in town that
everybody knows everybody knows what
I've been doin man's a lot of people
don't recognize me since the weight loss
since he launched his campaign Stevens
become known as the campaigning caddy
give you one of them cards then if you
have a look on there there's the website
yeah any money fest doors on there I'm
Bobby I'd want to be leaflets to the
diet not there you go you will be get
them to the door don't you worry about
that let's go three ducks so you're
gonna win i think i will ya I think it'd
be brilliant in this town that one big
part you freedo good morning everyone I
know it's really really horrible it's
pouring down with rain but I just want
to welcome you to tax cheats corner
enough is enough we need people and we
need our government to make sure that
everybody pays the tax that is due it's
quite a big thing isn't it what your
dad's doing and you guys sort of not
you're embarrassed are you you know dad
your dad out on the street I'm not I
think it and I'm not embarrassed it's
just a bit awkward at school when people
ask you questions what they asking you
and just why is he doing it and how like
why do you think he can win because it's
quite unlikely say and what do you say
to them um I said I think he can win but
you have to have quite a lot of faith in
Him because it's completely on his own
people need to know what I'm doing like
all candidates Richard gets one free
mailing to every house in the
constituency but he needs to raise money
to print leaflets anyway ruff he's
hoping to follow the lead of one
independent who's raised an incredible
amount through crowdfunding no I do I'm
going I just let me what a let me buy me
oh wise old pic end off your mask into
food
otherwise Claire right I'm hoping to be
7s next MP independent MP I've been
campaigning since last june and the key
campaign issues and the key pledges
relate to things like trying to prevent
overdevelopment of the countryside how
much money have you managed to raise and
how have you done it we've raised around
10,000 pounds and donations are still
coming in which is quite incredible and
we wouldn't have been able to you know
achieve all that we have achieved in
terms of our publicity all our leaflets
our banners of course we have to pay for
higher of halls and things like that the
big question is are you gonna win i
think i am going to win oh no I
shouldn't say that Robert sir Oh décor
look Craig every independent says
they're gonna win what makes you think
you really are going to win well it's
because of the feedback i'm guessing
it's you know I don't sort of go to bed
and say I'm going to win because I will
will it off obviously I do will it I do
want it I I think you dream about
winning oh gosh yes all the time yes and
I think about it a lot as well and I
think about what i would do and and you
know imagine being in the house it
covers and all of it I mean I imagine
all of that but it's the feedback I'm
getting and people are telling me all
the time that one they're going to vote
for me to their offering to help and
three they're donating money and fall
they want to see a change
back in Cheltenham a ukulele band is
playing in a pub upstairs Richard is
about to launch his manifesto so what's
happening tonight Richard open meeting
first one slightly nervous slight
trepidation I just don't know how many
people are going to turn up what I'd
really like is a roomful like people
standing around the edges but say yeah
we'll see yeah okay good come on
everyone my name is Richard I'm standing
as an independent at the election in May
I'm also standing as an independent as
none of our political parties and in
particular none of our political leaders
have any vision I would hold an in-out
referendum on Europe I would increase
the minimum wage to the living wage it's
time for change had enough so thank you
for coming i really appreciate your
coming out tonight
I think it went really well it's just
it's tinged with slight disappointment
about the number of people but but
actually they were passionate they were
here for the right reasons all of them
and it was great the level of engagement
that they had many of those people did
you know
yeah a lot a lot of them I do always
look for the positives when these things
but I have spoken out and there's
there's a huge value in saying the words
out loud and that is a really really
good rehearsal you know if nothing else
is asking for the hustings you know
we've got 11 coming up from a very early
age relation nights with have been in
the event for me you know it's almost
like a sporting event it's going to be
surreal it really is being involved just
things like going to the count you know
we're just being involved in that and
the drama of that and yeah I hope there
is a bit of drama involved in that